d'habitude idriss da silva donne des
cours de hip hop
aujourd'hui c'est lui l'élève il est
venu découvrir le concept des hip hop
dayz 90 on nous parlait mais on était
pourtant aujourd'hui le musicalité le
style le groove le filet nixon les hip
hop games ont été créés par romuald
brizolier champion du monde de hip hop
en 2009
cette année le concept s'installe à
saint quentin en yvelines dans le cadre
des pulsations urbaine une thématique
chère à l'agglomération à magny les
hameaux johanna faye a proposé un stage
d'initiation au hip hop game ce concept
durant tout un après-midi c'est s'amuser
ne surtout pas se juger et juste
s'écouter
et pas voir leurs hôtes des taxes est
actionné dedans c'est quoi ton général
est à quatre groupes sont composés de
quatre personnes et en fait ces quatre
personnels vont faire tour à tour des
égouts des jeux les équipes s'affrontent
lors d'un show en plusieurs épreuves
improvisé avec l'autre joué autour d'un
objet l'ipo games recherche une
dimension théâtrale dans la danse sur
trois musiques avoir trois les seules
différences trois ans ont dit pendant
trois personnages différents et on suit
quand la musique switch pouvoir souhait
de ce personnage
le hip hop game ce concept une
performance à mi chemin entre battle les
créations
pas
dernière date d'initiation samedi 10
novembre à trappes
avant le show de hip hop game ce concept
à guyancourt le samedi 17 novembre